alright looks like we're clear I can't
believe it's the weekend and I'm at
scared this is the best place to hide
why of all the places we could hide why
do I have to sit here and skew whoa
where's the last place anyone would
think we would hide the scene of our
supposed crime dummies we're safe here
I'd rather be in jail than its gay guys
guys Stan guys thank God just stay right
there grandpa I know all about the deal
I know what we have to do how'd you find
us here figured you guys fighting
somewhere this the first place I thought
to look mm-hmm yeah I guess we're dummy
talk any whoa whoa whoa guys listen my
stupid grand plan a bunch of other old
people made the deal with manbearpig
it's here because of their greediness
shut up grandpa I know where to go but I
need your help I'm gonna face manbearpig
and put an end to this deal are you lady
we just saw a member pic take down Satan
what the hell are we supposed to do
against it we have to try
attention school shooters again we have
you surrounded
again come out with your hands up we
just said it's cute
listen we know what to do now drop to
the ground and put your hands on your
heads
no I need to face manbearpig we have
orders you're coming with us
belay those orders I've been a fool
denying manbearpig existence and I
didn't realize it till I went home my
wife started a new life without me I
wanted to give up but instead I robbed a
bank in st. Denis and I went to an
island north of Cuba after I came back
that's when it all caught up with me
all the stagecoaches I arrived all the
horses I had stole for what we're
nothing if we don't believe in each
other and god damn it it's never too
late to start trying to do the right
thing do you think you know what that is
boys yes I do we're gonna face
manbearpig
[Music]
you